hey david if there were a mandatory gun
buyback in the united states
could it really work would people really
participate
very complicated question so let's first
just make sure we're on the same page if
you mean
could the united states say all guns
must be turned in and we will buy them
off of you
you don't get that if you don't repeal
the second amendment i
i spent some time reading about this i
don't see any way that there could be
a nationwide overarching
umbrella mandatory gun buyback without
changing the fact
that people do have a right to own
firearms as confirmed by the supreme
court now if you want to look at
something different like for example
a certain type of firearm has been
banned
and if you have one you have to turn it
in you will have a higher success rate
with that
both legally and in terms of getting
getting uh societal participation
but i don't see how in a country with a
second amendment
you can do a mandatory gun buyback so my
first question would be
how do you address the second amendment
you have to dismantle that right
which the supreme court precedent
supports
in order to do it if you could do it
okay
cost really is an issue i mean we have
300 million
firearms in is it 300 or 350 million
firearms
floating around in the united states
this is why when we talk about well
demilitarize the police yes police with
no guns
in the u.s it's tougher because so many
people have
guns in countries where fewer citizens
have guns
sure i think that's an obstacle here uh
so so then what is the cost because of
the number of guns that are floating
around
could be hundreds of billions of dollars
it could be high hundreds of billions of
dollars depending on
how it would be structured i know that
the government can just
you know not even it's not even print
it's digitally create money
but i see that as very tough politically
to imagine
and then if you could get through the
legal and the financial
the truth is that some other much less
aggressive acts
haven't been super successful i looked
at the new york
safe act and it saw of
it was based on assault weapons of the
million
that are registered in the state i
believe only 45
000 assault weapons were turned in
that's very very low compliance
now there are places that have been able
to do this the uk
new zealand australia they have smaller
populations
fewer guns floating around national gun
registries so
by and large the country knows where a
lot of those guns are
and they don't have anything in their
constitution that has deemed gun
ownership a right
it's it's a these are laws and the laws
can be changed
they had a lot of success there the
problem i have
believing this would be feasible as an
immediate next step in the united states
as some have suggested is that the genie
is out of the bottle in terms of
the second amendment in terms of the
number of guns that are out in
circulation so i think to really
if this is your priority and and i
believe that there is lower hanging
fruit that we should be looking at first
to create a better infrastructure where
then we could maybe start getting some
guns off of the street but if you want
to go first to a gun buyback
you first have to deal with the second
amendment you secondly have to deal with
the financial piece and third
how do you enforce it law enforcement
would not be able to enforce it in even
a few years
given the number of guns that are out
there what exactly
would be the plan i'm not being
defeatist i'm just being a realist and i
would love
for you to tell me where i'm wrong on
this